عقدان كاملا على الانطلاقه العربيه تحتفل
بعيدها العشرين لشخص ساقدمها لكم بمناسبه
مرور 20 عاما على انطلاقه قناه العربيه
[موسيقى]
في مثل هذا اليوم قبل 20 عاما الثالث من
مارس عام 2003 كانت الانطلاقه انطلاقه
قناه العربيه من رحم تحولات تاريخيه
واحداث كبرى شهدتها المنطقه العربيه
والعالم 20 عاما التزمت خلالها قناه
العربيه بنهج حيادي غير منحاز الا للمشاهد
العربي وللكلمه المسؤوله والحقيقه المؤكده
والخبر دقيق والتعليق الحر لتكون مصدرا
موثوقا للاخبار المشاهد العربي حيث ما
كانت
على مدار 20 عاما احداث كبرى في المنطقه
العربيه والعالم واكبتها قناه العربيه من
كل جوانبها وجميع تفاصيلها فمنذ انطلاقتها
عملت على تغطيه حرب العراق عام 2003 مرورا
باغتيال رفيق الحريري في لبنان وما تبعه
من احداث غيرت معالم المنطقه اضافه الى
احداث الربيع العربي وجائحه كورونا
والانسحاب الامريكي من افغانستان والحرب
الروسيه الاوكرانيه وزلزال تركيا وغيرها
الكثير
معتمده على احدث تقنيات استطاعت العربيه
خلال السنواتها العشرين مواكبه التحولات
الكبرى التي عرفها العالم العربي والعالم
وتمكنت من تلبيه احتياجات الجمهور العربي
لخدمه اخباريه على مدار الساعه العربيه
كانت سباقه دوما للاستفاده من التكنولوجيا
المتطوره التي تشهدها صناعه الاعلام لتكون
علامه كبرى تتمتع بموثقيه في العالم
عقدان من الزمن عملت العربيه خلالها على
التوسع لتتحول الى شبكه اخباريه متكامله
تضم قناه العربيه وقناه الحدث التي تقدم
نشرات اخباريه على مدار الساعه اضافه الى
مجموعه واسعه من المنصات الرقميه التي
يتابعها ويتفاعل معها الملايين حول العالم
متابعوه شبكه العربيه على منصات التواصل
الاجتماعي بلغوا حوالي 180 مليون متابع
فيما يسجل محتوى الذي ينتجه فريق التحرير
ومراسل القناه مشاهدات تفوق المليار
مشاهده شهريا وهي ارقام تضع العربيه في
صداره القنوات الاخباريه العربيه وحتى
دوليه منها
وختاما وفي هذه المناسبه الغاليه على
قلوبنا جميعا اتقدم بالشكر الجزيل
والامتنان لجميع الزملاء والعاملين في
قناه العربيه مبروك للعربيه عامها العشرين
وكل عام والعربيه بخير وجمهورنا الحبيب
بالف خير